General find [ __ ] shitty and dumb
watch like you know if you tell me
something dumb I'm gonna kill you no
it's just like it's just like cool like
McDonald's all this fast food [ __ ] pizza
bad for you why is your body making them
taste good what no no I think that's how
it is
it's the argument of all the healthy
[ __ ] tastes gross and all the bad [ __ ]
for you tastes good yes that's that is
if that isn't the biggest troll your
brain has played on you bro like I don't
know what it is I thought Evolution was
meant to like help you you know why why
have we not evolved to a point where at
least healthy foods had like taste a bit
better because humans are privilege this
is even bigger question right yeah if we
were to evolve as say a species and you
know how we're like oh yeah [ __ ] rats
they love [ __ ] peanut butter they
love it they love it right why do we not
all like the same things
what do you mean why do we not all enjoy
the same Foods
it's blunt
I'm just saying
what you're asking is for us to be
programmed the same where we just think
that every like oh carrots are top 10
delicious uh Foods everyone on Earth
agrees okay but here's the question
right why is it that humans turned out
that way but animals you know you know
God didn't like this whatever mystical
[ __ ] made the Earth didn't make pizza we
did that yeah we came up with that [ __ ]
right we were like uh this weed [ __ ]
this uh cheese stuff that we figured out
how to make we should start combining
[ __ ] we did that that's not that they
didn't well I think when Evolution
happened they didn't know that the Big
Mac super Royale was gonna exist
they weren't prepared that's on us the
one we threw that into them one thing
that can be it Darwin of
also another question another [ __ ] up
Evolution has led us to the Big Mac
sauce we you we keep saying this
Evolution thing like every evolution is
good not every evolution is good what's
a bad Evolution trait think of like half
the [ __ ] birds that died how do you
die out as a bird you gotta be really
[ __ ] trolling to die out as a bird
that's the whole point of evolution
Connor so it's survival of the finish
what are you talking about so the point
is you're implying that every single
evolution is a good Evolution not true
not every evolution it turns out to be
as beneficial as others that's why only
the best one keeps going right maybe we
are the humans that are not doing good
but we just figure out how to survive
anyway but we're evolving into shitty
traits but we're just really good at
[ __ ] slapping a massive Band-Aid on
it think about it right yeah I mean
that's that's a genuine argument yeah
if you are implying that every evolution
is good not every single level the way
you
evolution is the whole point of
evolution is survival of the Fitters if
if we we broke the game if we evolved it
doesn't matter anymore God we [ __ ] it
up what I'm trying to say is every
evolution should be a good Evolution
because if it isn't then we would die
off but yes I believe we have gotten too
smart and we have broken the Evolution
game okay what if for example what if we
are just we're probably just another
like Pawn in this game right like the
next evolution of humanity is might be
the newer version and this version of us
might be the ones that die out in a
couple thousand years who the [ __ ] no
here's the thing right yeah if we truly
lived in a [ __ ] Evolution let's do it
right yeah people who had like incurable
diseases would would die out yes right
but we don't let that happen because
we're not [ __ ] monsters we're trying
to help people exactly we have evolved I
guess empathy
first of all the most powerful trait a
heart
a soul Evolution doesn't care about your
fear feelings well then we we evolved
evolution is just the epitome of get
good so [ __ ] your feelings the first
humans yeah yeah whatever the [ __ ] they
were yeah we even cared about other
weaker members of the the group in
evolution we don't know why why did we
evolve to be like this I don't [ __ ]
know it's not like and realistically
it's not a a trait that helps us to
survive in any way but but
imagine that humans don't you're
suggesting then that only humans are
creatures that are able to feel empathy
no that's not true why do any creatures
develop it I mean it could be beneficial
I mean I guess it's beneficial to the
Past right yeah if you have like a herd
kind of like culture then if they didn't
exist in animals packs wouldn't exist
we've gotten to the point where we're
like we're not concerned about the next
evolution of human beings we're just
trying to [ __ ] get everyone to get
alive well the thing is we don't we're
not concerned about it because we
haven't been around long enough to feel
that change yeah right like like birds
for example have been around for
literally millions of years so obviously
they've felt that change humans have
only been around for like what a couple
thousands but we see we see uh changes
in every like generation of people you
know like of course like you know today
[ __ ] that we did yeah us today are
nothing like humans a thousand years ago
yeah no I I I I I that's Evolution
already and that there are some we're
taller yeah we're taller yes we're more
Alpha yes
John Wick to get our [ __ ] Zeus you
know what I mean like we had to make
that [ __ ] up
yeah I mean there are like they're like
habits within us that you know that we
don't understand yeah and we still have
and I've you know people think it's due
to Evolution like I don't know why
people like you see someone yawning and
you feel like the need to yawn
you were like talking Evolution like are
youon
tell me tell me why that happens can we
see someone yawns it sends from your
eyes it sends a signal to your brain
where your brain says you're nice okay
oh this might be the most scientifically
inaccurate traffic of all time but [ __ ]
it let's roll
this isn't science this is shower
thoughts yeah right
so humans right great great awesome so I
like them our priority is to make as
many of us as possible yeah if you think
about the yeah the survival Instinct of
us right Japan's sweating right now yeah
but why why why do like none of us give
a [ __ ] about doing it what
that doesn't even have to do with the
fact that we're trying down
it's not even about that it's like every
human I think most humans on planet
Earth can agree that I think
subconsciously we're all thinking right
now [ __ ] planet's dying we have to save
the planet you ask someone how do we do
it everyone's like
I'll [ __ ] know we know how to do it
but the people in charge on [ __ ]
doing it yeah exactly see lack of
empathy
I mean it's it's lack of like it's it's
it's a bad trait of the human mind I
guess if we're going into this place
where we can't really conceptualize a
problem this vast right we're only able
to conceptualize literally either
stories we hear about or most of us our
immediate problems and the immediate
issues that's the real shower thought
did we evolve to develop empathy or did
we evolve further where we think we have
empathy
no no that's [ __ ]
do we actually have empathy can we just
build the knowledge where we think that
empathy is a healthy social construct do
you think because let's be real it was
like why do you think for example every
zombie apocalypse film that happens
right immediately it's like oh the the
monsters want the zombies the monsters
were within we're the real monsters all
right
because at the end of the day when it
comes to actual survival right like
think of every apocalyptic movie you
don't see people being [ __ ]
empathetic they're the ones that die
first yep that's a zombie movie though
okay yeah but let's say for example okay
okay here's where it's all came from
right yeah is it you know human beings
have have the natural
um want to be accepted in their like
group yes that's what we've just evolved
to do yes empathy is just a branch of
that it just came from that yeah because
it's just a social construct yeah but
and it just boils down to the need that
we want for the government we just want
to fit in
do you think we've gotten too smart
maybe because here's the thing no you
know we're done look at what we're
[ __ ] doing to the planet we're
clearly dumb as [ __ ] but the thing is
the thing is we got smart enough to [ __ ]
it up but not smart enough to figure out
how to fix it yeah as a group right I
think any creature that develops the
science of thinking about science
of making stuff yeah and they're not
thinking about how it's going to work
but also and then just implementing it
yeah but also like for example you you
talked about you know the you know it
should be
um human nature to self-preserve you
know to make more of us to preserve the
human race but we've gotten so smart
that in some places of the human race
we've gone smart enough to just not make
that decision yeah you know which which
completely we've gone to the idea now
that it's not a natural instinct Joe
Rogan conversation I haven't even had
any DMT no I I wanna I wanna shoot some
[ __ ] horse tranquilizer or something
is that what you do is that what you're
doing you're all holding imaginary
blocks right now
everyone will all be holding up everyone
must think we'd be like high as [ __ ] man
if I was like 90 years old and had
classes you guys would just think I'm
the expert like I'd be honest so you
gotta talk well that's why he's got the
glass I wouldn't even plan for this [ __ ]
I just happened to bring glasses yeah
yeah [ __ ] it's I don't I don't know I
feel like these are damaged [ __ ] we are
we are dumb no we are we've developed
really specific parts of our brain to
think that we're smarter but in reality
we're still [ __ ] dumb in a lot of
that actual like apes we're still Apes
we're just monkeys in shoes yeah we
we're Apes floating on a rock like
flying through space but we've been
we've oh we're smart enough to know that
we're smart
was smart enough to develop things I
could exactly like [ __ ] wipe us off
the face of the Earth We're smart enough
we're not only smart enough to know that
but we're also smart enough to not give
a [ __ ] isn't that [ __ ] up isn't that
[ __ ] up we're fully aware that we are
just a tiny Speck of dust in space and
with but and yet we are still smart
enough to be like yeah but [ __ ]
whatever you know I I I'm I want to go
to work this is one of the weirdest
[ __ ] episodes of trash taste I think
we've ever [ __ ] filmed yo trash
tastes philosophers Where You Are